hello my name is amanda lund and i'm an
associate professor in the departments
of dermatology and pathology at nyu
langone health in new york city
and i'm excited to have the opportunity
to share today with you the work that
we're doing investigating the role of
the tumor micro environment
in mediating immune suppression and in
particular
uh present to you some data
focus on the dermal lymphatic
vasculature which we think is a really
critical and dynamic component of this
immune suppressive tumor
microenvironment
i have no conflicts of interest to
disclose
and so like
many of you we're very interested in
understanding how
to activate and mobilize anti-tumor
immune responses for the benefit of the
patient
and i think we appreciate across the
field that there are multiple barriers
in place that limit the ability of our
systemic hosts immune responses to
uh really target tumors for durable and
persistent uh control
and these include first the ability to
actually activate an antigen-specific
adaptive immune response
during tumor development and in response
to therapy
but even after we've done so that
we must mobilize uh and recruit that
effector immune response into the tumor
microenvironment where it can actually
engage its target
and then even if that is successful that
there remain multiple overlapping
mechanisms of immune suppression that
are activated within the tumor
microenvironment
many of which i think we still
have yet to fully understand that
inhibit the ability of that effector
immune response to mediate a direct
tumor control
and so it's by sort of approaching the
oncology from these multiple different
perspectives that i think we can design
uh
patient therapies that uh are
personalized to the specific needs and
barriers that exist
within their own
immune response
and really broaden the scope of
immunotherapy
across tumor types and across patient
populations
and so the particular component of this
tumor microenvironment that we are
interested in as i mentioned is the
lymphatic vasculature this is a really
unique vascular system and that it
mediates the unidirectional movement of
fluid cells and of course tumor cells
from peripheral tissues and tumors
through a network of vessels to
secondary lymphoid organs and the lymph
node
where
important uh interactions occur that
mediate the activation of immune
surveillance and thereby drive potent
systemic adaptive immunity
and these vessels which you see over
here in this micrograph this is a
mirroring uh dermis with lymphatic
vessels are shown here in green
and blood vessels are shown in magenta
are unique vessels they're large they
lack a continuous basement membrane they
are not invested with muscle cells and
it's for these reasons that they've been
assumed to be really passive players in
the movement of immunological
information from these peripheral tissue
sites to draining lymph nodes where
cells and fluid can move through open
gaps between the endothelial cells
and and rapidly transport
to draining lymph nodes
so we and others both in the context of
tumors and in the context of viral
infection have
robustly demonstrated that the efficient
movement of antigen presenting cells and
fluid from peripheral tissues to the
lymph node
via the lymphatics is absolutely
required for efficient protective
immunity and in the absence of this
vasculature
you significantly impair host responses
to challenge driving exacerbated
pathology at the local site of
inflammation
but what we've also begun to understand
is that rather than being passive
conduits or sort of a plumbing system if
you will
we and others now appreciate that these
vessels are dynamic that they regulate
expression of molecules that enable
cellular interactions in very specific
ways and can actually also actively
regulate the fluid that is moved through
the system and thereby tune the
information that actually arrives in
these training lymph nodes and so we now
think about the lymphatic vasculature
not as a passive system but as an active
component of the tumor microenvironment
and of the anti-tumor immune response
that can be mobilized
within a patient
but more classically in the context of
cancer the way that the lymphatic
vasculature
has been appreciated as for its role in
regional metastasis as the necessary
route from a developing tumor
to lymph nodes lymphatic vessels are the
road over which tumor cells gain access
to these lymph nodes and we know from
studies using sentinel lymph node biopsy
that the presence of tumor cells within
that first draining lymph node is a poor
prognostic indicator in many tumor types
including melanoma
and that the probability that a tumor
cell acts as these accesses these lymph
nodes
can be to some extent predicted by the
number of lymphatic vessels that are
present in and around a developing tumor
and these vessels seem to also increase
with stage
um furthermore we know that the level or
the density of lymphatic vasculature in
and around tumor can be manipulated or
driven by the expression of vascular
endothelial growth factors in particular
vegfc which can be derived both from
both the tumor cells themselves as well
as from the infiltrating inflammatory
myeloid compartment
um and so
you know lymphatic vasculature uh and
lymph angiogenesis or the proliferation
of lymphatic vasculature has been sort
of an established
and appreciated component of the tumor
mic environment for some time
and what's important is you can see here
that in the context of in this case the
primary cutaneous melanoma but the
lymphatic vessels which you see here in
green labeled by protoplanin are present
in and around this developing tumor
and importantly also sort of nestled
within and around the inflammatory
infiltrating cytotoxic t cell response
which you see here um in teal
and so
you know the question has really become
whether
whether or not the lymphatic vessel
changes that we see that are associated
with tumor development are simply
contributing to progression by providing
these exit routes for metastatic tumor
cells or if rather this remodeling that
happens might directly impact tumor
immunity and therefore indirectly impact
um tumor progression
and so um for sort of many years now
we've been asking this question um to
truly try to understand how changes in
lymphatic vasculature that evolved with
the tumor might directly contribute to
the ability of the host to in the first
case see that tumor
um and then following activation of
antitumor immune responses do these
vessels continue to play a role in the
maintenance of that effector t t-cell
response within
the established tumor or in in the case
of therapy
in response to therapy
and what we have shown is that if you
over express that lymphangiogenic factor
vegfc that you do increase immune
surveillance you
facilitate transport of antigen
presenting cells and antigen to lymph
nodes to activate t cell responses
but as a result of this new activation
you also activate multiple overlapping
adaptive mechanisms of immune
suppression
um because you create this sort of hot
smoldering tumor microenvironment
vegfc over expressing or lymphang tumors
are
much more responsive to immunotherapy
suggesting the hypothesis that you might
be able to use the lymphangiogenic
microenvironment as a sort of proxy for
a hot um or inflamed tumor
what we are now showing in the lab um in
unpublished work is that um once
antigen-specific t cells do accumulate
within the tumor microenvironment um
that a subset of these t cells actually
uh simply exit right back out and they
do so through the lymphatic vasculature
and the molecular mechanisms that
regulate this process may provide new
checkpoints
to regulate regulate t cell retention
and effector function within the tumor
but finally what i want to talk to you
about today is that we also know that in
the context of these hot or inflamed
tumor microenvironments that lymphatic
endothelial cells that line these
capillaries themselves are very
responsive
that they
sort of switch their phenotype
as a function of the accumulation of
cytotoxic cytokines such as interferon
gamma and that when you decouple the
crosstalk between the lymphatic
vasculature and the infiltrating
cytotoxic t cell response
you can actually improve tumor control
and so that's what i want to show you
today
and to really drive home this idea that
lymphatic vessels are not simply
required for immune surveillance but
that also continue to contribute
to the ongoing immune response
we did this sort of proof of principle
experiment using viral infection in mice
either wild type or that lack on
completely lack dermal lymphatic vessels
what you can see is that when you infect
animals that completely lack a dermal
lymphatic vasculature and you control
for
a viral load
that these mice that lack lymphatic
vessels exhibit this
dramatic and exacerbated and persistent
inflammatory response as measured by
skin thickness so that's at a time point
where virus has been completely cleared
the
tissue at the site of infection sort of
retains this really pathological um
inflamed inflammatory state
and you can see this at the microscopic
level if we look by h and e you can see
at this late 20-day time point a
dramatic thickening of the dermis and
epidermis as well as this robust and uh
persistent and inappropriate
accumulation of leukocytes within this
tissue and so this just really
highlights i think the important role
that exit from tissue and the these
lymphatic vessels themselves play
in allowing a return to homeostasis
which of course in the context of tumor
is is something that we wish to
avoid other thing that we know about the
lymphatic vasculature which is quite
unique is that the endothelial cells
that compose
these lymphatic capillaries
have intrinsic immunological properties
that are just beginning to be
appreciated
notably we have shown that lymphatic
endothelial cells can scavenge and cross
present antigen
when they do this in the context of a
steady state or a tumor
their high expression of an immune
inhibitory molecule pedia1 drives
cd8 positive t cell dysfunction or
deletion
um but they can also in the context of
viral infection actually hold on to this
antigen and pass it off to dendritic
cells to support membranes so there's
some really interesting properties of
these lymphatic endothelial cells um
that may directly regulate local immune
responses that really remain to be
teased apart um in in vivo um and of
course in patients
what we also know is that if you look in
the tumor microenvironment and you could
see some of this in the human
image
that i
showed you
is that t cells are often in very close
proximity to tumor associated lymphatic
vessels the vessel you see here in green
the cd8 t cell in light blue
and this really got us
thinking about whether or not lymphatic
vasculature in the context of the tumor
microenvironment itself
might adopt some of these immune
regulatory
processes that are more typical of
lymphatic endothelial cells in the lymph
node
and actually interact with effector cv8
t cells to modify their function
so this is where the work of a talented
graduate student in the lab who has
since graduated and the first thing that
he did was really ask whether or not uh
the lymphatic endothelial cells present
in and around a developing tumor
exhibited expression of that immune
regulatory checkpoint pdl1 which we of
course all appreciate for its role in
immune suppression
and what had been shown previously and
what's consistent in our data that if
you look at the lymphatic endothelial
cells by flow or blood endothelial cells
that these black lines indicate
lymphatic endothelial cells are largely
negative for pdl1 and skin at steady
state
whereas blood endothelial cells express
some basal levels of pdl1 even at steady
state and skin
but what was really interesting to see
was a dramatic up-regulation of pedia-1
by lymphatic endothelial cells in the
context of american melanoma
and really equal levels of expression
if not less expression by the blend
endothelial cells so this really got us
excited by by this finding and we looked
at expression of pdf1 by lymphatic
endothelial cells across multiple tumor
models
and what you can see is that the level
of pdl1 expressed by these endothelial
cells is tuned by its microenvironment
and if we actually plot the infiltrating
cd8 t cell response in these tumors
versus the
extent to which the lymphatics are
expressing pdl1 you can see this nice
correlation
between infiltrating cytotoxic t cell
immunity and the activation
of pdl-1 expression
by lymphatic capillaries within and
around the tumor
um so this again suggests that there was
a really finely tuned crosstalk between
cytotoxic immunity
and lymphatic endothelial cells and we
were curious as to whether or not
we could demonstrate that pdl1 expressed
by this non-hematopoietic
cell type
could have any relevance for anti-tumor
immune control
and uh so what we did is we performed
similar experiments as have been done in
the context of chronic lcmv where we
generated bone marrow chimeras such that
mice were either wild-type expressed pbl
one on both their hematopoietic and
non-hematopoietic cells
transferred wild-type bone marrow into
pdl-1 knockout mice such that their
hematopoietic cells were proficient in
expression of pdl-1 but all host cells
including the endothelium would be
negative for pdl1
and then we did the converse where we
took a pdl-1 knockout bone marrow
transferred that into wild-type animals
to create hematopoietic pdl-1
knockouts in our initial experiments we
used the b16 f10 murine melanoma which
is a poor responder to single agent
immunotherapy and we did not see a
significant change into in tumor growth
in these chimeras
but when we actually started to explore
the correlates of response within these
mice what we began to appreciate is that
both the non-hematopoietic knockout as
well as the hematopoietic knockout
enabled a
reinvigoration of a cd8 t cell response
within the tumor
associated with enhanced expression of
activation markers including pdf one
um suggesting that both pdo one from
hematopoietic and non-metaphoric cells
has a role to play
in controlling the anti-tumor t cell
response
what was interesting however is if we
looked outside the tumor
at circulating lymphocytes either in the
in the draining lymph node in the spleen
or in the blood
here we saw that only the hematopoietic
knockout
had really mobilized increased systemic
response to the tumor
whereas the non-metabolic response
looked similar
on circulating t-cell populations and
this suggested the anatomical
compartmentalization
of pdl-1
and and more recent work from ira
mellman's group and others consistent
with this that suggests that
hematopoietic pedia one plays a dominant
role in limiting the expansion of a cd
antigen-specific cd positive t cell
response and that we would then suggest
that non-hematopoietic pdl-1 including
that expressed by the endothelial cells
controls local t cell function
at the inflamed site
to eliminate the role of this systemic
priming on the effect that we were
seeing we activated antigen-specific t
cells in this case the ot-1 transgenic t
cell and transferred them into
tumor-bearing mice that expressed the
matched tumor antigen
um
what we saw is that when we do this
these t cells of course accumulate
within the tumor micro environment
directly
and
exhibit improved tumor control over wild
type mice in both the non-hematopoietic
and hematopoietic compartment
providing more direct evidence that pdl1
expressed by non-tumor non-hematopoietic
cells
directly in the tumor microenvironment
play a role in limiting tumor control
as i mentioned the b16f10 is really
poorly responsive to single agent
immunotherapy and so we started using a
more immunogenic marine melanoma the
yammer 1.7 which is potently responsive
to single agent checkpoint blockade and
now when we transfer transplant these
tumors into mice with a
non-hematopoietic pdl-1 knockout you can
see spontaneous and persistent tumor
control
initiating around 10 to 11 days post
tumor transplant
again altogether providing a uh
important evidence that
non-hematopoietic pdl-1 limits local
effector t-cell function
so we were curious whether or not this
was tumor specific or if rather
lymphatic endothelial cells are
responsive to cytotoxic immunity across
various different types of
microenvironments and therefore might
contribute to the tuning of effector
function
more broadly
and so to do this we looked at lymphatic
endothelial cells by flow cytometry in
skin that was infected with vaccinia
virus
in skin where we had activated a delayed
type hypersensitivity response
or in skin where we had activated in a
micromod based model of psoriasis
and what you can appreciate in these red
lines is that in all three cases
lymphatic endothelial cells exhibit a
dramatic upregulation of pdl-1
within this inflamed skin um
specifically and not within other
contralateral or adjacent normal
standing types again suggesting that
lymphatics are in some way this really
uh finely tuned switch um that are
activated by cytotoxic immunity
these models also provided a an
opportunity to explore the dynamics of
this upregulation
and using vaccinia virus as a model if
we looked at
blood endothelial cells
shown on the left and lymphatic
endothelial cells seen here on the right
um that
really it's between day three and day
seven where we begin to see the robust
upregulation of pdl1 on both of these
endothelial cell compartments
and of course this is a time poor point
where we know um that the de novo
generated antigen-specific immune
response
activated in the draining lymph node of
this uh infected skin site
is beginning to accumulate
again really suggesting to us that it's
the infiltration of cytotoxic
t cells
that is activating this
response tested this directly in tumors
and asked whether or not if we mobilized
an engine-specific immune response
could we boost the level of expression
of pdl-1 on the lymphatic endothelium
which really links
the uh again this idea that that it's
the crosstalk between these two
components that really matters
and to do this we used an attenuated
listeria based vaccine
that either did or did not express a
matched tumor antigen in this case ova
when we infect tumor bearing mice you
can see we drive a really beautiful
antigen specific cd8 positive t cell
response systemically and within the
tumor only when we have that matched
antigen and not when we do not
and what we see is that only when you
activate the recruitment of that antigen
specific cd8 positive t cell response
and not a bystander generic antilisteria
response do you boost pdl1 expression on
lymphatic endothelial cells
we ask this question in another way we
use an adaptive transfer of ot1 tcr
transgenic t cells and when we look in
the micro environment of tumors being
contractively controlled by ot-1 t cells
you can see this adaptive upregulation
of pedialon by the lymphatic endothelial
cells
and so all together this suggests that
it's the accumulation and infiltration
of specifically antigen-specific
cd8-positive t-cells
that is
able to tune the level of expression of
pdl-1 on the lymphatic vasculature
so of course this suggested that
interfering gamma was at play and if we
block interference gamma either in the
context of viral infection or in the
setting of implanted nearing melanomas
you can see that we significantly reduce
the level of expression of pdl-1 by
lymphatic endothelial cells
um and and consistent with this we see
that interfering gamma itself xvipo is
sufficient to drive expression of pdo1
by lymphatics and it does so in a stat
one dependent ways we're using canonical
and efferent gamma and mediated
signaling
um and so this provided us an
interesting opportunity to think about
well how do we actually decouple
the
crosstalk between the cytotoxic t cell
lymphatic endothelium to understand the
specific role this adaptation adaptation
plays in anti-tumor immune responses
and so to do this we generated lymphatic
specific interference gamma receptor
knockouts i'm showing you here some
proof of principle data using a
constitutive live one cree i will show
you data as well with an inducible
prox1create in both cases um this drives
loss of interference gamma receptor on
lymphatic endothelial cells
you can see that lymphatic endothelial
cells ex vivo now fail to phosphorylate
stat one in response to interference
gamma treatment
um and as a result are unable to
increase expression of the interference
of pdl1 in the presence of interferon
gamma x-vivo
and so this gives us a really
interesting model by which to understand
the functionality of this lymphatic
response in the context of immunity
and so we decided to look at this um in
vivo in two different models first um
our viral infection of the skin and then
of course in our immunogenic tumors
um because we really hypothesize that
lymphatic vessel sensing of interference
gamma was in in the first place sort of
a common mechanism of response to
cytotoxicity and that in in
across multiple contexts may play a role
in sort of tuning the height of the
effector immune response within tissue
to enable a rapid and appropriate return
to homeostasis
so in the context of viral infection we
might predict um that activation of pdl1
by lymphatic endothelium
limits the effector responses in that
tissue
so we first
validated that loss of interference
gamma receptor lymphatic endothelial
cells prevents pbl1 upregulation
in our infected skin and in fact it does
which is what you see here
um and consisting of our hypothesis and
really interesting what we observed
at
10 days post infection
when viral titers are essentially the
same
that we had this dramatic
increase in pathology you can see an
increase in epidermal thickness you can
see an increase in dermal thickness and
what appears to be an exacerbated
infiltration of infiltrating leukocytes
um this uh leukocyte infiltration seemed
to be largely driven by t cells both cd4
and cd8t cell presence within the skin
was elevated and if you look
specifically at a viral specific cva
positive t cell response you can see an
almost twofold increase in uh effector
cd8 positive t cells within this tissue
and this is really dramatic as as the
numbers of t cells in these um tissue of
of these animals is already very very
high at this time point
um when we look systemically we saw a
note increase in the in the expansion of
the b r specific response and so these
data all together
really suggested
that
there was some uh loss of control of the
effector response within the tissue
at the site of infection itself
what's of course interesting is that if
you look at bible control um at time
points in and around where this
pathology becomes really evident you can
see that the this elevated effector
response has no real effect on
control of the virus and so consistent
with the hypothesis that i presented
this really suggests that um
pdl1 within tissue and and in this case
on lymphatic endothelial cells is
regulating this balance between
protective immunity and tissue
homeostasis and that there's a point at
which more effector immunity
is not better in the context of these
normally resolving inflammatory
responses
now of course that's not the case in the
tumor and what we want to do in the
setting of tumor is really drive that
protective immunity to end point
and so we implanted our immunogenic mary
melanoma into these lymphatic specific
knockout mice you can see that we impair
the expression of pdl1 um when we do
this um and now we can ask whether or
not this impacts the ability of the of
the mouse to
mobilize a more persistent and durable
cd8 positive t-cell response and that's
in fact exactly what we see
um so now
with with simply the removal of the
interference gamma receptor from the
lymphatic vasculature you get um
spontaneous control of a subset of these
tumors that control is mediated by the
cd8 positive t cell response because if
we delete cda t cells shown here in
green we lose that advantage
and this leads to a significant survival
advantage in these really rapidly
growing implantable
tumor models
as i mentioned we confirmed this in a
second cree
in this case an inducible proxy one
create that we activated one week prior
to tumor implantation and again what you
see
is the significant delay in tumor growth
across multiple animals um that extends
survival and so this is the first data
that that demonstrates in vivo in a
lymphatic specific way
that the dynamics or the integration of
signals from the tumor micro environment
by lymphatic endothelial cells can
directly contribute to the effector
phase of a anti-tumor immune response
i mentioned in the beginning that
lymphatic endothelial cells can scavenge
antigen and we had shown now quite some
time ago that they do this in the
context of the tumor microenvironment
and it i want to point out here that it
remains unclear as to whether or not the
functionality of pdl1 on these
endothelial cells acts in concert
with scavenged antigen and antigen
presentation by these cells or whether
it acts sort of independent
of that antigen present presenting
capability and that's something that
still um remains to be fully determined
and so that i would just like to
conclude by sort of acknowledging uh
what i think has been really a a
central tenet of immunology um for for a
long time which is that inflammation is
self-limiting and that interference
gamma helps threshold responses by
activating compensatory immune
mechanisms in multiple
cell types both local to the challenge
and distant and that the combination of
these mechanisms together maintain the
fidelity of the immune response and an
appropriate return to tissue homeostasis
what i've shown you here today is that
non-hematopoietic pdl-1
limits effector t cell function in tumor
microenvironments um the endothelial
cells are a major component of this
non-hematopoietic pdl-1
and that pdl1 is driven by on all
lymphatic endothelial cells by their
exquisite um
sensitivity
to interferon gamma produced locally
within the tumor microenvironment
and that by interrupting the ability of
the lymphatic endothelium to sense the
cytotoxic immune response we can
actually drive more durable and
persistent tumor control in urine
melanomas
and with that i will just uh thank my
group this work was done by ryan lane
who's a talented uh graduate student in
the lab um and we're of course uh
they're interested in continuing to
understand the role of interfering gamma
and pdl-1 on endothelial cells
in the context of tumors and
non-malignant inflammation
thank you